all right Isaac I have one question for
you
yeah is it okay if I marry your mom of
course I love you as a father thank you
all right so today Beverly Hills and uh
seemingly it's gonna be a big day for me
yes today I am shopping for an
engagement ring for TIFF finally pulling
the trigger on it and um yeah we'll see
what kind of rings we want I don't know
I've no idea what I'm doing
sure real diamond you sure just play
diamond so getting an engagement ring
for Tiffany has been just a one big
question mark cuz I don't know what I'm
doing why are introduced me to his
friend his family owns a jewelry store
here in Beverly Hills and I have to say
the experience here was very
enlightening just because I don't know
anything about jewelry I don't know
anything about diamonds and I sure as
hell don't know anything about
engagement rings this guy you know he
kind of knew my backstory I told him you
know where I was coming from what I
wanted to do with the proposal what I do
for a living
and so through all that he was able to
tell me exactly what I needed to hear
found the right guy for the right job
for the right ring for the right girl I
guess another thing too that really
helped us out is so TIFF has a Pinterest
and I feel like every girl has a
Pinterest and I also feel like every
girl has a Pinterest section that is
strictly about weddings and that's where
I got all my clues from and I feel like
she left it there on purpose like she
knew like she had to give me clues
because I'm oblivious with all this kind
of stuff so she knew she need to leave
it somewhere and I guess she was a she
was smart enough to know that I was
smart enough that I would go on
Pinterest look
I don't know because it was too easy it
was just all there all the information
was there I'm gonna put out a deposit
right now serious it's getting real
serious actually
all right Isaac I have one question for
you yeah is it okay if I marry your mom
of course I love you as a father thank
you
what are you looking forward to the most
I'm looking for e2o how do you know I
don't know what I'm looking forward to
do you think anything's gonna change no
nothing's gonna change right is we're
already a family
ever ever seen a diamond before no never
seen guys before
you
so last week I picked up the band and
then and today I picked out my diamond
that he gave me basically each time I go
see him he has he already has three
things laid out for me you said he
looked at nine different stones and he
picked out three from those nine stones
and he presented me really today and
then he taught me everything about how
to look at diamond D I even looked
through the the glass and look at the
imperfections of the diamonds you're
totally Tommy the carrots you know how
how large a diamond is and how much
value that holds versus the the color of
a diamond like Sumter's discoloration
sometimes and that also holds a
different value for the diamond and also
the imperfections of a diamond the
grades of it and I and he taught me how
to look for it and he was like you see
that line there has the imperfection
makes it look like dust marks to me
under like better Isaac Minya Minya
Minya more I think we got our stone we
got our stone got our band no regular
role we're ready to he's gonna put it
all together now and I'm to pick it up
next weekend we're gonna undo this thing
you're excited yeah
defended by the game that's great so so
when is it gonna happen which next week
next Thursday one week from now I'm
proposing Wow Wow you will stage one
second
during the jke news right yes on this
particular day I'm gonna fabricate a
news article and when Julia's doing her
session with the news I'm gonna tell her
save my fake article for the very last
one and so at the end the night when
they're about to wrap shaky news in
comes a fake article written completely
by me and it's probably gonna be super
like on the nose like in true love news
a man proposed to his girlfriend while
she's storming for her job something
like that I don't know I haven't written
it yet but something to that effect
where it's like he's exactly what's
about to happen and I guess the effect
should be like hey that sounds like hey
that's me hopefully that's the effect I
don't know like I wanted to kind of have
it sink in before it actually happens
just for a split second so she could
process it all and then I'm gonna sneak
up from behind her I'm going through the
back door of the office
and propose so that's the big master
plan and yeah all right so today is the
day I am going to pick up the ring and
I'm going to finalize a deal and it's
about to be is about to get like serious
now no turning back now now that I was
gonna turn back anyways but it's true
just got back from Beverly Hills and got
this thing I just saw Gio on the way in
and she wants to see it
hold on sangmi give you guys a sneak
peek first this is the box I was given
here's the ring
Oh
all right SP day
we're Casey present me Mom this ring you
excited yep I'm super I'm so excited now
that I'm starting to get nervous
I'm nervous you're nervous - yeah why
are you nervous
I don't know I'm nervous cuz I don't
know why I'm nervous either
AHA I'm nervous for no reason one time
yesterday
what if Kiki asked you to fairy you
asked her that and she was like no not
to something did you actually believe
she's over up for something he did it
sure it the first man named I was like
no or not oh my hand is oh it fits you
we're gonna sneak in we're gonna hijack
JK news for a couple minutes and I'm
gonna propose to her and we're all gonna
cry I need you to be my cameraman can
you take this camera and video the whole
thing for me of course
Katie thank you
hey Jory yeah
thank you all right we are ready Isaac
are you ready hey I am getting really
nervous now I don't know why all right
we're gonna head out
nervous because on how it's gonna go
okay
hi this is the most nervous I've been in
a long time and this is definitely like
butterflies to the max all right we just
pulled up we just pulled up to the
office super nervous I think I just keep
saying super nervous I don't even so
nervous now
I don't even know what else is safe but
I'm just nervous now are you ready for
this so ready I'm so ready let's do this
in mother romance news a man realizes
his life was changed for the better the
day he first met the girl of his dreams
that's so nice owing many thanks to rap
concerts and Korean barbeque the two
bonded quickly he soon saw the potential
of a loving girlfriend in her eyes but
it was the warmth of a nurturing mother
in which he saw her true beauty wait a
minute what she created a home for him
accepted him into her family and over
the course of four years she had taught
and demonstrated to him everyday just
what love is love is a perfection
comprised of imperfect parts the
imperfections allow for improvement and
growth and although we all may not be
perfect people
oh my god oh you happy
you're beating down like wait a minute
hey that's all the guys that really just
happened oh we're gonna marry the
Louisville